Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. It is so great to
be back here today. We have so much to talk about.
First, let me explain what happened last week
now understandably. Last week I was gone. And
understandably, many people assumed reasonably
so that this was part of my paternity leave,
me being gone last week. It was not. I was
suddenly in an emergency fashion. Temporarily
a single dad last week and ended up having to
bail on the entire week. Let me tell you what's
going on. So, as many of you know, had a baby some
weeks ago and took about ten days off initially
and then slowly kind of worked back into doing
the show. But limiting my other stuff with the
idea that once the baby is an age in a couple of
months where she's no longer sleeping all day,
then I would take some other time off and
whatever. But in the meantime, wanted to get
back to hosting and just kind of a little bit
of a sense of normality. And last Sunday night,
I was ready to wake up Monday and do the show when
at 3 a.m. my girlfriend wakes me up and says, Sir,
I'm not feeling well. She doesn't really
call me sir, but okay. She said, I'm not
feeling well. Can we take my blood pressure? With
postpartum moms, you monitor for something called
postpartum pre-eclampsia. And one of the signs of
that is high blood pressure. And we take her blood
pressure. This is 3 a.m. Take her blood pressure.
Blood pressure's fine. 305 She says I'm I'm just
really like my abdomen just hurts. I'm not feeling
well. And we're thinking, that's weird. All right.
Let's let's call the O.B., the obstetrician
there on call line and see what they say.
By 310 in the morning, she's really not feeling
well. And by 315, she's doubled over on her couch.
And at this point, I'm saying, what what is this?
This this doesn't seem good. My girlfriend has a
really high pain tolerance normally, like
during the during the birth. She asked,
you know, when would people normally start, like
getting anesthesia? And the nurses said, oh,
24 hours ago, most people would
have had anesthesia. She was like,
This really isn't that bad. So when she's doubled
over, I know something, something bad is going on
by a by 320 in the morning. She says, you got to
call 911. And at this point, I know it's bad. I
call 911. And she is just in such abdominal pain
that she's unable to move. 330 in the morning,
ambulance shows up and she's rushed to the
hospital and says, Take care of the baby.
So all of a sudden I am saying, I got to make
formula. I need to figure out what's going on.
Long story short, by about 11 in the morning,
about 8 hours into the E.R. stay, they figure out
that she has a duodenum perforation. The duodenum
is sort of like between it's below the stomach,
but above the next thing, I guess it
would be like the small intestine. I think
there's a perforation there and we're thinking,
what? What are the odds, young woman, healthy,
all of a sudden a perforation, that it's just
so unlikely. And what we find out and of course,
with these things, you never know 100%, but what
the surgeon and the OB, what everybody agreed upon
is this is a rare but known side effect of a
significant use of ibuprofen. Ibuprofen will why?
After the C-section, she was put on ibuprofen,
both in the hospital and then after the fact,
every 6 hours. That's a lot of ibuprofen. And this
is sometimes you get an ulcer from ibuprofen use,
you can have gastritis and every once in
a while you get a perforation. And this
was that rare case. This is it's a really serious
condition there. Sometimes postpartum perforations
in other countries and different situations lead
to death. And so she was rushed into surgery.
It's a relatively simple surgery, but with
very kind of intense, complicated recovery,
including not being able to eat or drink
anything for five days, which is it's a
form of psychological torture. So that's why I was
gone last week. I was going between the hospital
and taking care of a baby initially by myself,
and eventually we got help from family. And it
was crazy. I mean, I don't you know, there's a
million different details I could give you about
how how difficult situations are in hospitals,
even in good hospitals. And, you know,
also the realization of like, how do single moms
do it? You know, when we just randomly here, oh,
Barack Obama was raised by a single mom. Oh, all
right. Like. The day to day of that. You know,
once you get down to the logistics, once you
get down to the specifics of what that is,
it's incredible. It really is. And I was always a
supporter of all, you know, funding and programs
to help parents in general and single parents and
all that. I am double or triple now a supporter
after having experienced that for a week,
particularly knowing very little about babies,
I have to say. So fortunately, now everybody's
on the mend. It is like a 4 to 6 week recovery
period in total, but things have gotten much,
much better and everybody's reunited. I'm no
longer doing the single dad thing,
but and by the way, the other thing.
Single parents who work. I mean, this was a
this was a particularly acute situation, right,
where my girlfriend's in the hospital and I'm home
with a baby and etc.. But. There. There's no way I
could have worked. I mean, it's just impossible,
right? I was doing the pediatrician appointments,
managing the feeding, coordinating help
with the family that was able to help you.
It was it's literally 24 seven. And I just I just
don't even know I don't even know how I could have
possibly done any job. And I was lucky enough
to have a job where I'm the boss. And I can say,
well, I'm off for the week. And of course, we
had we had great villains. We had Luke Beasley
and we had Pat and we had Ferran, and we had
the resources to do that. But imagine that,
number one, I had an employer saying, you know,
we start at 915, where are you? And it's like, Oh,
I can't make it for a week. I can barely leave
the one room in my house where I'm doing things.
But imagine also that I my income went to zero.
As a result of that, as many people don't have
paid time off or sick time or whatever the case
may be. So incredibly eye opening and horrifying.
But hopefully now on the up and up.
And of course, we've got to monitor for
complications. And sometimes after when you
have various tubes inside of you for a week,
when they remove the tubes, you've got to watch
what happens and you've got to watch for infection
and all of these different things. So we're not
completely out of the woods yet, but it's so great
to have a little bit of a sense of normality
and to be back on the show today. But that was
last week. It was not really paternity leave in
a sense. It was in that it was connected to the
birth. And interestingly, that this was the the OB
team that was part of everything, even though this
was not an OB related procedure. The OB team was
was involved in everything they said. Our entire
practice is now changing how we do postpartum
Advil. We used to do it what's called PRN. The
patient just requests it when they feel they need
it and then they often wouldn't. And then they'd
wake up and they'd be in pain. So we would just
just do it every 6 hours and we're not going to
do that anymore. So crazy situation. Good to be
back. Let's talk now about the outlook for 2022.